This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个由 iHeart 制作的播客。保证由真人录制。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目聚焦于黑男性的生活经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他地方往往并不安全，但你是在跟一个经验丰富的持证专业人士探讨这些。有多少男人背负着一副重铠甲，向世界发出信号：不要招惹我。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。收听《艰难成长的教训》，
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。2%。这是指那些在电梯旁还有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将为你在我们这个陌生现代世界中剖析关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的姿态迎来蜕变。收听《2%》。也就是“2%”，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。当一群女性发现她们约会过的对象竟然都是同一个惯犯骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他必须得到应有的惩罚。我们常说，相信你的好闺蜜们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
收听播客《闺蜜们》（The Girlfriends），相信我，宝贝，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。在《回看往昔》（Look Back At It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我而言是一个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段日子的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊20世纪80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。那确实是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人群体来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看往昔》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控使人怀上双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
你曾多次篡改了这项特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷情网》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemisbeke and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back for another episode of the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another guest episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. One of my favorite things about running a podcast is that I get to just like have these hour long conversations with people who have just done really cool, really unexpected things with their life, things that I can honestly say I don't think anybody else has ever done. and today we have one of those people.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要面对后果了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷情网》播客。大家好。我是杰米斯·贝克（Jemisbeke），欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个带你探讨二十多岁时遇到的重大改变、关键时刻和人生过渡期的播客，以及这些对我们的心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到本期播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一期访谈节目，我们将在此剖析二十多岁时的心理学。经营播客我最喜欢的一点就是，我能和那些在生活中做出超级酷、超级出乎意料的事情的人进行长达一小时的对话，这些事情是我可以诚实地说，我觉得其他人绝对没有做过的事情，而今天我们就迎来了这样一位嘉宾。
George Appling has a Harvard MBA. He was the CEO of a multi-billion dollar company and he now runs one of the world's largest Renaissance fairs. He runs a beer business. He owns a ranch in Austin. Between those two timelines, he has also done a dozen of other really cool, interesting things, all because he understands this theory of matching your,
乔治·阿普林（George Appling）拥有哈佛商学院 MBA 学位。曾是一家数十亿美元公司的首席执行官，而他现在经营着世界上最大的文艺复兴集市之一。他经营着一家蜂蜜酒生意。他在奥斯汀拥有一座牧场。在这两段经历之间，他还做过十几个其他非常酷、非常有意思的事情，这一切都是因为他理解了这样一种理论：将你的
career path to your personality and your identity. In fact, through his own work and his own research, he's actually identified the five types of careers people are drawn to and how we can use this theory to identify what we should be doing with our lives at this very moment. I am so excited for you guys to hear our conversation. I'm so excited to have him on the show. Without further ado, George Appling, welcome to the psychology of your 20s. Thank you so much. much for coming on. Thank you, Gemma, for having me. Yeah. I'm super excited about this one as we were talking about before we started recording. I've spoken to you for a little bit here, but can you tell the listeners about yourself and about what you do, what you like, who you are? Sure.
职业道路与你的个性及身份相匹配。事实上，通过他自己的工作和研究，他实际上找出了人们倾向于选择的五种职业类型，以及我们如何利用这一理论来明确我们在此时此刻的生活中究竟该做些什么。我真的非常高兴大家能听到我们的对话。我也非常高兴能邀请他来到节目中。废话不多说，乔治·阿普林，欢迎来到《你二十多岁的心理学》。非常感谢你来到这里。谢谢杰米（Gemma）邀请我。是的。我对这期节目超级兴奋，正如我们在录音前聊天时提到的那样，我和你在这里聊了一会儿，不过你能跟听众们介绍一下你自己，以及你是做什么的、你喜欢什么、你是一个什么样的人吗？当然。
My name's George. I'm originally from a small town in Texas. I had a, you know, a kind of a regular career in business. So I did, you know, I did strategy consulting for a long time at firms. like McKinsey and Booz, and then I did cell phone distribution for a long time. I ended up being the CEO of a billion dollar company. But then that kind of enabled me to do something completely different. So I threw all that stuff away and decided to be a passionpreneur. And so I've got a bunch of companies that I'm deeply, deeply in love with. The core of that is Sherwood Forest Fair. You had mentioned a medieval thing that you guys do. So I run a medieval theme park. And so we run for Saturdays and Sundays in March and April, and we have 177,000 guests in 17 days, over 10,000 people a day.
我叫乔治。我原本来自德克萨斯州的一个小镇。我有一段，你知道的，挺常规的商业职业生涯。所以，你知道的，我在麦肯锡（McKinsey）和博斯（Booz）这样的公司做了很长时间的战略咨询，后来我又做了很长时间的手机分销。我最终成为了一家价值十亿美元的公司的首席执行官。但随后，那段经历让我能够去做一些完全不同的事情。所以我把那些东西全都抛在脑后，决定成为一名“激情创业者”（passionpreneur）。因此，我创办了一堆我深深、深深热爱的公司。其中的核心是舍伍德森林集市（Sherwood Forest Fair）。你之前提到过你们举办的中世纪活动。所以我经营着一个中世纪主题公园。我们在三月和四月的周六和周日营业，我们在17天里接待了17.7万名游客，每天超过1万多人。
And we're all Robin Hood all the time, jousting and falconry and drinking meat and eating turkey late. So that's the core. And then I've got a Robin Hood summer camp and a mead business, which is fermented honey, an audio software company, an executive coaching business. And then I wrote a book that hit Amazon number one. It's about choosing the relationship between your passion and your work, which is different than saying your work and your passion have to be the same thing. I've got five different choices in the book, and it lays out a framework for you to pick the one that's right for you. And I'm just kind of running around the country talking mostly to university students about the book. So I know that's like the most complicated intro, anyone's probably ever done, because I just do a lot of stuff.
我们全天候都在扮演罗宾汉，进行骑士比武、驯鹰表演、喝着蜂蜜酒、吃着火鸡腿。所以这就是核心。然后我还有一个罗宾汉夏令营、一个蜂蜜酒生意（就是发酵蜂蜜）、一家音频软件公司、一家高管教练公司。接着我写了一本书，登上了亚马逊畅销榜第一名。这本书讲的是如何选择你的激情与工作之间的关系，这与“你的工作和激情必须是同一件事”是不同的。我在书中给出了五种不同的选择，并为你提供了一个框架，让你挑选出最适合你的那一个。我基本上就是在全国各地奔波，主要向大学生们谈论这本书。我知道这可能是任何人做过的最复杂的自我介绍了，因为我确实做了很多事情。
I've got three kids and nine horses and, you know, I'm living my best life. Okay, but I love that story because it shows that you can kind of do it all and have all these different areas of you, like, being fulfilled. As soon as you said me to business, I was like, okay, this guy is, well, actually, as soon as you said Robin Hood and Renaissance Fair, I was like, this guy is so cool. And I love having guests on who have like a change in their life and go. from doing like the corporate thing to the passion thing, especially when they did that, obviously not in their 20s and did it later in life and have become fulfilled through that. This is what really drew me into your book and into what you have to say. You have this really cool story.
我有三个孩子、九匹马，你知道的，我正在过着我最好的生活。好的，但我真的很喜欢这个故事，因为它表明你确实可以做到面面俱到，并且拥有你生活中的所有这些不同方面，让你感到满足。你一说蜂蜜酒生意，我就想，好吧，这家伙——其实，你一说罗宾汉和文艺复兴集市，我就想，这家伙太酷了。我特别喜欢邀请那些经历过人生转变、从做公司高管转向追求热情的嘉宾，特别是当他们并非在二十多岁时、而是在人生稍后的阶段才做出这种转变，并通过这种方式获得满足感。这正是真正吸引我阅读你的书并倾听你观点的原因。你有一个非常酷的故事。
You were a strategy consultant. You were the CEO of a billion dollar company. Now you have like what seems like the coolest profession ever. Part of that change, I'm sure, for you was also discovering these five. five career paths and probably doing a lot of deep work within yourself to figure this out. Can you tell people what these are, these five career paths you describe? Sure. And these are, I thought about these paths for years and years and years before putting them down into the book. So, you know, I had that little, you know, that little app called
你曾是一名战略顾问。你曾是一家价值十亿美元公司的首席执行官。现在你拥有了一个看起来可以说是史上最酷的职业。我相信，对你而言，这一转变的部分原因也是发现了这五种职业道路，并且可能在内心深处做了大量的工作来弄清楚这一点。你能跟听众们讲讲这五条职业道路分别是什么吗？当然。这些道路我在写进书里之前，已经思考了整整好几年。所以，你知道的，我曾经用那个叫做
Microsoft Note. Yeah. And I would like type in notes for decades, you know, I mean, probably like two decades, not three or four, but trying to kind of really congeal into what these paths are. So there are five paths, and the paths are different ways that passion and work can relate to each other. One is, of course, passion. And that's where your passion and your work are the same thing now. And I am typically talking to, you know, people in their 20s. And so that, you know, path makes sense if you have the capability and the desire to monetize a passion and your need for, you know,
Microsoft Note 的小应用。是的。我会把笔记一条条打进去，记录了几十年，你知道的，大概是二十年左右，不是三四十年，我一直在努力将这些道路真正凝练成型。所以一共有五条道路，而这几条道路代表了激情与工作相互关联的不同方式。其中之一，当然就是“激情当即（Passion Now）”。这就是你的激情和工作现在就是同一回事。而我通常是在跟，你知道的，二十多岁的人对话。所以，（这种道路）如果你有能力和意愿将激情商业化，并且你对，你知道的，
financial security is relatively low. If all those things are true, then the passion now path makes sense for you. There's the independent path where your passion and your work don't have anything to do with one another. I think that tends to be the default path of humans where like the world will do that to you. But in my framework, there's a certain set of conditions where that's the right thing for you. And my belief is that if you choose the independent path and you say to yourself, my passion and my work are not going to be the same thing, then you're going to be more productive and content and fulfilled because you decided, as opposed to letting the world decide that for you.
财务安全的需求相对较低，那么这种道路对你来说就是合情合理的。还有一种是“独立（Independent）”道路，即你的激情和你的工作之间没有任何关系。我认为这往往是人类的默认道路，世界就会这样强加于你。但在我的框架中，存在着某种特定的条件，在那种情况下这就是对你而言正确的事情。我的信念是，如果你选择了独立道路，并且对自己说：我的激情和我的工作将不会是同一回事，那么你会变得更有生产力、更满足、更有成就感，因为这是你自己的决定，而不是任由世界为你做决定。
There's the experiment path, which is typically for people who don't know what their passion is. Experiment just means open yourself up to things, try a bunch of stuff. It could be trying things in different geographies. I spent most of a year in Melbourne, by the way. It could be trying different functions and we're going to be. It could be trying business versus government versus non-profit. It could be learning a new language. It's whatever.
还有“实验（Experiment）”道路，这通常适用于那些不知道自己的激情所在的人。“实验”的意思就是向各种事物敞开心扉，尝试各种各样的事情。这可以是在不同的地理位置尝试各种事物的体验。顺便说一句，我在墨尔本度过了大部分一年的时间。这也可以是尝试不同的职能部门。这可以是在商业、政府与非营利组织之间进行尝试。这可以是学习一门新语言。无论是什么，
It's kind of exposing yourself to as much as possible to look for that spark. That's the experiment path. There's the money path, which, you know, we all know the, well, you did strategy consulting. So you knew the friends who went to Goldman Sachs and Morgan Stanley. Like they had to have tons of money and they just weren't going to be able to calm down until that happened. And so if your need for financial security is that high, it may be. be the right thing for you to do to go on the money path. And then the last one is the balanced path, and that's what I did. And the balanced path is you go through a regular career, hopefully you love it,
它有点像是尽可能让自己接触更多的事物，去寻找那一点火花。这就是实验道路。还有一种是“金钱（Money）”道路，你知道的，大家都知道，嗯，你做过战略咨询。所以你认识那些去了高盛（Goldman Sachs）和摩根士丹利（Morgan Stanley）的朋友。他们必须赚大把的钱，而且在实现这个目标之前，他们根本无法安心。所以，如果你对财务安全的需求就是这么高，那么走上金钱这条路，对你来说可能就是正确的事情。最后一条是“平衡（Balanced）”道路，这也是我走的路。平衡道路就是你经历一份常规的职业，希望你爱上它，
and it's about building capabilities and wealth and reputation and network so that 5, 10, 15, 20 years later, you switch to the passion path and your probability of success is higher. So that's what I did. I did all my strategy consulting and running cell phone distribution companies. And so then when I turned over to the passion path 16 years ago, I had savings and I had capabilities and I had reputation and network and it made my chances of success higher. So I love this framework because I think everyone kind of fits somewhere. Do you think that like with the passion path as well, that could be like the volunteer path, I guess, like people who sacrifice, like. their whole mission in life is to do good for others. Is that like where that one kind of fits in?
它的核心是建立能力、财富、声誉和人脉，这样在5年、10年、15年、20年之后，你就可以转型去走激情道路，而你成功的概率会更高。这就是我所做的。我做过所有的战略咨询，也经营过手机分销公司。因此，当我在16年前转向激情道路时，我已经有了积蓄、能力、声誉和人脉，这让我成功的几率更高了。我非常喜欢这个框架，因为我觉得每个人都能在其中找到自己的定位。你觉得，对于激情道路而言，这也可以是“志愿服务”的道路吗？我想象中，比如那些做出牺牲的人，
Well, I think it's a lot of different things. So first off, I'll back up and say, I've got a pretty decent data set on people going through their framework and choosing the five paths. So I think I'm at like over 3,000 people have taken my little online tool. It takes like five minutes. And they choose. And what's beautiful about the result is that the top one is balanced. and it's at like 26%.
他们一生的使命就是为他人做好事。这算是其中一种契合的情况吗？嗯，我觉得这里面包含了很多不同的事情。首先，我要补充一点，关于人们如何经历这个框架并选择这五条道路，我掌握了相当不错的数据。所以我想大概有超过3,000人使用了我的在线小工具。这大概只需要花五分钟。然后他们做出选择。而这个结果美妙的地方在于，排在第一位的是“平衡”，占比大约是26%。
And the bottom one is Passion now, but it's at like 16. And so, you know, there's five paths. If the world were distributed equally, they would be 20% each. But they're like 16 to 26 or something. Like each of the five paths really has an audience. So I feel really good about the definitions.
而排在最后的是“激情当即”，但占比大约是16%。所以，你知道的，一共有五条道路。如果全世界是均等分配的，那么每条道路应该是20%。但它们的比例大概在16%到26%之间。这五条道路中的每一条确实都有它的受众。所以我对这些定义感到非常满意。
To your question, though, about the Passion Pass, yeah, there's a lot going on there. So there are, you know, a lot of artists want to do that path where you know, I've got a friend named Roxanne, and she just wasn't going to be satisfied with the universe if she wasn't making music. Like, that was it. She's going to make music.
不过，回到你关于激情道路的问题上，是的，那里有很多事情在发生。所以，你知道的，有很多艺术家都想走这条路，就像，我有一个朋友叫罗克珊（Roxanne），如果她不创作音乐，她就无法对这个宇宙感到满意。事情就是这样。她就是要创作音乐。
And she realized the probability of financial success is very low. And so she structured her life to be able to live frugally. But she lives this brilliant life. Like she will, she lives in America. And she will fly to Spain for, you know, a summer and put a hat in the street and play music and make 300 Euro on day one and day two she's a tourist and day three she puts a hat down and plays music and makes 200 euro and day four she's a tourist and she's done that over and over and over again but you know she's she's staying in a youth hostel for 20 euro a night not 200 or or more right
而她意识到获得财务成功的几率非常低。因此，她构建了自己的生活，以便能够过上简朴的生活。但她过着一种极其精彩的生活。比如，她住在美国，而她会为了，你知道的，一个夏天飞去西班牙，在街头放一顶帽子然后演奏音乐，第一天就能赚300欧元，第二天她就当个游客，第三天她再把帽子放下来演奏音乐赚200欧元，第四天她又去当游客，她一遍又一遍地这样重复着，但是，你知道的，她住的是一晚20欧元而不是200欧元甚至更多的青年旅舍，对吧？
so you know if you're going to follow an arts path at a young age you might make it big financially but you probably won't and so you got to get your head around being fulfilled you know, without being rich. But there's all sorts of things on the path. When I talk to these university students all the time, and I'll find people who, they're just completely in love with cars. And if they get to sell cars for a living,
所以，你知道的，如果你在年轻时选择走艺术道路，你也许能在财务上大获成功，但你很可能不会。所以你必须做好心理准备，去追求内心充实，你知道的，哪怕并不富有。但这上面有各种各样的事情。当我跟这些大学生们聊天时，我会发现有些人，他们简直对汽车爱得深沉。如果他们能以卖车为生，
they're just over the moon. That's it. All they want to do is just sell cars and drive cars and play with cars and talk about cars. Like, okay. You know, there's a lot of jobs, you know, where you can think about cars all day. Yeah.
他们就会欣喜若狂。就是这样。他们只想卖车、开车、玩车、谈论汽车。好吧。你知道的，有很多工作，你知道的，你可以整天想着汽车。是的。
So it's a broader path than people would think. In the nonprofit, you hit that. There's a lot of people that do that. There's a lot of people drawn to public service that would be on the passion path. A lot of people in teaching are drawn to it by a genuine passion. So it could be a lot of things. Yeah. See, this is the thing about the passion path that I always say to people because I did the independent path for a long time
所以这条路的涵盖范围比人们想象的要广泛。在非营利领域，你提到了这一点。有很多人都在做那个。有很多被公共服务吸引的人会选择激情道路。很多从事教学的人都是出于一种真挚的热情而被吸引过来的。所以它可以涵盖很多事情。是的。看，这就是关于激情道路的那个特点，我总是对人们说，因为我曾长时期走过独立道路，
where I was like balancing this podcast and I worked as a consultant and I definitely burnt out. The thing with the passion path is, yeah, you're right. You have to be okay to make no money for probably a long time slash ever. And I've also found, and I don't know if you found this as well, do people who monetize their passion fall out of love with it for a little bit? Or do you think that this path is really the one that you just fall back in love with it time and time again? I remember when the podcast became my full-time job, you immediately love it less because there's all this stuff wrapped up in financial security.
当时我既要平衡这个播客，又要兼职做顾问，我绝对是精疲力竭了。关于激情道路，有一点是，是的，你说得对。你必须能够接受可能很长一段时间甚至永远都赚不到钱。而且我也发现，我不知道你是不是也发现了这一点，那些将自己的激情商业化的人，会不会有一段时间对它失去热爱？或者你觉得这条路真的是那种让你一次又一次重新爱上它的路吗？我记得当播客成为我的全职工作时，你立刻就会对它少了几分爱，因为里面夹杂了太多与财务安全挂钩的东西。
Have you found that in some of the interviews? some of the people you've spoken to, yeah? Yes. This is something I talk about in my university talks and in the book that it's not unusual for a passion to dim when it becomes your livelihood. That being said, I think there are variations in there. And so the one I talk about a lot is painting. It seems to happen a lot that when your passion is painting and you've, you're bringing a vision of something beautiful to your mind to canvas with oil and then showing it to the world,
你在一些采访中发现过这种情况吗？在跟你聊过的一些人身上，是的吗？是的。这也是我在大学演讲和书中经常谈到的一点：当一项激情成为你的生计来源时，它的光芒变得黯淡，并不是什么罕见的事。话虽如此，我认为这其中也存在着差异。所以我经常谈到的一个例子就是绘画。似乎经常发生这样的情况：当你的绘画是出于激情，当你把脑海中某种美丽事物的愿景用油彩画上画布，然后向世界展示时，
you're just completely and utterly in love with it. But when you're bringing someone else's vision to life on canvas with oil and you're getting paid for it and it has a deadline and they have critiques, it just sucks, right? It's just complete shit that you have to say to hate it. So painters moving from doing it for love to doing it for money, I think has a pretty bad success rate. And so, like, that's the trick about the passion path is you got to, you know, two different thoughts. One, you've got to dig deep on the question of, do I really, really want to do this for a living? You've got to dig deep on that.
你是完全且彻底地爱着它的。但当你是把别人的愿景用油彩在画布上实现，而且你因此获得报酬，并且它有截止日期、别人会对它评头论足时，这就太糟糕了，对吧？这简直烂透了，你不得不说你开始讨厌它了。所以，画家从为了爱而画画转变为为了钱而画画，我认为其成功的几率相当低。所以，这就是关于激情道路的秘诀所在，你必须，你知道的，有两点思考。第一，你必须深入挖掘这样一个问题：我真的、真的想以此为生吗？你必须在这上面进行深度挖掘。
And the second thing to think about is the passion is something that typically lasts forever or decades. And it animates you. It's kind of your reason for being. I talk a lot about Iki-Gai, which is a Japanese framework in the book. And it's something that really gives you energy all the time. And it can be distinguished from something that you really enjoy. It can be distinguished from something that is pleasurable. It can be distinguished for something you love, right?
需要思考的第二点是，激情通常是能持续一生或数十年的东西。它能让你充满活力。它有点像是你存在的意义。我在书中经常谈到“ikigai”（生而有为），这是一个日本概念框架。它是那种能一直赋予你能量的东西。它可以区别于那种你单纯觉得好玩的事。它可以区别于那种能带来感官愉悦的事。它可以区别于你所爱的事物，对吧？
It's something that is giving you energy and a driving force for hopefully ever. So you've got to dig deep on whether that's true. I personally really relate to that. People are always like, how can your passion be podcasting? And I'm like, no, because since I was a kid, like, this is the medium that I loved. Like, I have these visceral memories, like, these very intense memories of listening to podcasts with my mom, like, listening to this American life when I was like a child and being like, this is amazing. Like, I love what they do with this. And, yeah, it feels great that I found it so early.
它是那种能够赋予你能量、并成为你源源不断的动力驱动力的东西，最好能持续永远。所以你必须深入挖掘这是否属实。我个人对此真的深有共鸣。人们总是问：你怎么能把做播客当成你的激情呢？而我会说：不，因为从小时候起，这就是我所热爱媒介。我有这种刻骨铭心的记忆，那种非常强烈跟妈妈一起听播客的记忆，比如当我还是个孩子的时候听《This American Life》（美国生活），然后觉得：这太棒了！我太喜欢他们用这种方式做的事了。而且，是的，能够这么早就找到它，感觉真的太棒了。
what would you say to people who, because this is my thought on this. I feel like I have all these conversations obviously with people in their 20s. A lot of people want to find their passion and their purpose as a means to fulfill them. What would you say to people who are looking at their life and being like, wait, I just don't have that. I don't have it now. Maybe I've never had anything like that. Yeah, I'd say three things. If I can, say, I've got to take notes now, so I can remember all of my three things.
你会对那些——因为这是我对此的想法。我觉得我显然一直在和二十多岁的人进行所有这些对话。很多人都想把找到自己的激情和目标作为实现自我满足的一种手段。你会对那些审视自己的生活然后觉得：等一下，我根本没有那个。我现在没有。也许我从来没有过这样的人说些什么呢？我会说三点。如果可以的话，我会说：我得做笔记了，好记住我这三点。
but I'm probably going to talk about digging, breadth, and work. Okay. So first, one of my favorite books in the last 10 years is Grit by Angela Duckworth. And one of the things she talked about in there is that passion is rarely, if ever, something you discover because you're sitting down and asking yourself the question, what am I passionate about? It just doesn't really work that way. It tends to be a spark of something that gets you excited. and then you start digging into it and you're like, oh, that's really interesting.
但我可能会谈到深度挖掘、广度和工作。好的。首先，我在过去10年里最喜欢的书之一是安吉拉·达克沃斯（Angela Duckworth）写的《坚毅》（Grit）。她在书中谈到的其中一件事是：激情很少、甚至几乎从来不是那种你坐下来问自己“我对什么充满激情？”就能凭空发现的东西。它其实不是那样运作的。它往往只是某种让你兴奋的火花，
Oh, and you keep going and you keep going and you keep going. So creating a passion in something tends to be a lot of work. It tends to be digging and going deeper and putting time into it, put an energy into it, getting to know people into it, reading about it. So passion is rarely a thunderstrike moment. It's usually a process to figure that out. So the first thing is,
然后你开始深入挖掘它，接着你会想：哦，这真的很有趣。哦，然后你不断继续，不断继续，不断继续。因此，在某件事上培养出激情往往需要做大量的工作。它往往需要深入挖掘、走得更深、投入时间、投入精力、去结识从事那个领域的人、去阅读相关的资料。所以，激情很少是一次电击般的灵光乍现时刻。弄清楚这一点通常是一个过程。所以第一点是，
that's my first suggestion. is don't expect to find the passion by sitting there asking yourself, looking at the blue sky, going, what am I passionate about? You can do that. And I've got a passion tree in my book to help you think about that. But just bear in mind, it's probably going to take some work. The second is breadth. And it's this idea that there's an incredible breadth of things that a human being can be passionate about. Podcast, Renaissance festivals. Like, this is going to be the weirdest thing you've ever heard. I think I've just fell in love. I think I'm passionate about analytical insight, meaning using math to solve a problem and coming up with something that no one else had come up with
这是我的第一个建议。不要指望通过坐在那里问自己、看着蓝天、然后问“我对什么充满激情？”来找到激情。你可以这么做。我的书里有一棵“激情树”来帮助你思考这个问题。但请记住，这可能需要付出一些努力。第二点是广度。这个概念指的是，人类可以对其充满激情的领域有着难以置信的广度。播客、文艺复兴集市。听着，这可能是你听过最奇怪的事情了。我想我刚刚坠入爱河了。我想我对“分析洞察力”充满激情，也就是利用数学来解决问题，并得出其他人从未得出过、
or that's hard to come up with. That, I just love that. And here's the example that's just the most boring thing you can imagine. A long time ago, I built a supply curve, a demand curve for paraffin wax. I had a Harvard MBA and I'm making a lot of money and I was just jazzed by analytical insight. So Brett, you could be passionate about so many things. And I mentioned cars and music. I mean, it's really. It's okay. Like you can be passionate about a lot of stuff. So open yourself, open your mind. And then the third thing, you know, work. Yeah, you might have to work at it to figure it out. Yeah. Which is, you know, I love that book, Grit as well. And a study that I always tell people about is that more than intelligence, pure intelligence, more than emotional intelligence,
或者很难得出的结论。那个，我简直爱死那个了。这就是那个你能想象到的最无聊的例子的体现。很久以前，我建立了一条供应曲线、一条石蜡的消费需求曲线。我拥有哈佛 MBA 学位，赚着大笔的钱，而我当时就是被这种分析洞察力给迷住了。所以广度，你可以对许许多多的事情充满激情。我提到了汽车和音乐。我的意思是，真的。这完全没问题。你可以对很多事情充满激情。所以敞开心扉，打开你的思维。然后第三点，你知道的，工作。是的，你可能得在这上面下功夫才能搞清楚它。是的。也就是，你知道的，我也非常喜欢《坚毅》这本书。而我总是告诉人们的一项研究是：比起纯粹的智商，比起情商，
more than anything, grit is the biggest predictor of success in passion, in intellectual pursuit, in money, in improving your skill. They have done this huge study that looks at this and they are like, what makes the best people the best? Because, you know, Taylor Swift isn't the best vocalist. And, like, there are certain athletes who don't actually have the best physique for their sport, and yet they become incredibly successful because they just want to work for it. So I love that you mention that book. It's, like, definitely required reading, if you like, if you like the podcast.
比起任何事情，坚毅才是激情、智力追求、金钱以及提升技能方面获得成功的最大预测指标。他们做过一项宏大的研究来探讨这个，他们会问：是什么让最优秀的人成为最顶尖的？因为，你知道的，泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）并不是最好的歌手。而且，你知道的，有些运动员其实并不具备最适合其运动项目的体格，然而他们却取得了不可思议的成功，因为他们只是愿意为之付出努力。所以我很高兴你提到这本书。如果你喜欢这个播客的话，这绝对是必读之作。
Yeah, I love that book. Also, I love your Taylor Swift example because the one I use is Ed Sheeran. If you listen to his music at 16, it's kind of awful. And he just worked and worked and worked. And now he's one of the biggest stars in the world. Yeah. And he's written so many songs. And also, I feel like he talks a lot about how he doesn't have this face for like commercial music. And he kind of like makes fun of himself. And it's like, yeah, but the work and the care and the love for it definitely comes through and makes people believe in what you're doing as well.
是的，我也很喜欢那本书。而且我特别喜欢你举的泰勒·斯威夫特的例子，因为我常用的是艾德·希兰（Ed Sheeran）。如果你听听他16岁时的音乐，其实有点惨不忍睹。而他只是不停地努力、努力、再努力。现在他成为了世界上最大牌的明星之一。是的。而且他写了那么多的歌。另外，我觉得他经常谈到自己其实并不长着一副适合做流行商业音乐的面孔，他甚至还会自嘲一番。这就像是：是的，但那种努力、那种用心以及对音乐的热爱绝对透过作品传递了出来，并让人们也相信你正在做的事情。
I want to shift gears. We've talked about passion a lot because I think that's often the path that a lot of people in their 20s care about. But the one I'm particularly drawn to talking about here is the experiment path. Now, am I correct in saying this is the least popular in your research? I think that is right. I mean, I could pull it up. Yeah, I think that is in last place, but, you know, like I said, each of these paths really has an audience. Yeah.
我想转换一下话题。我们聊了很多关于激情的话题，因为我认为这通常是许多二十多岁的人所关心的道路。但我特别想在这里探讨的是“实验”道路。那么，我说这是你研究中最不受欢迎的一条道路，对吗？我想是的。我的意思是，我可以把它调出来看看。是的，我想它确实排在最后，但正如我所说，正如我之前提到的，这些道路中的每一条确实都有其受众。是的。
And so the experiment path, it's basically to kind of paraphrase what you said before, this is like for people who are keen to just try different things and to, you know, be a woodworker one day, a tax accountant the next maybe, Birdwatcher, I'm thinking about my uncle who definitely like loves the experiment path. Why do you think, firstly, do you think this is an important path for people to be on their 20s and why do you think maybe people shy away from it? Yeah, one thing you said was, you know, felt drawn to experiment. I think in my mind, the experiment path is it's a choice you make and it typically is a choice you make because you don't know what your passion is. And so what, and you're going to go find it. And while you're going to find it, you're going to build skills,
所以实验道路，基本上就是用你之前的话来换个说法，这就像是给那些热衷于尝试不同事物的人准备的，比如今天当个木匠，明天或许当个税务会计，或者当个观鸟者——我想到了我的叔叔，他绝对是那种热爱实验道路的人。你为什么认为——首先，你认为这对二十多岁的人来说是一条重要的道路吗？为什么你认为人们可能会对它避而远之？是的，你刚才说的一点是，对实验感到吸引。在我看来，实验道路是一个你做出的选择，它通常是你因为不知道自己的激情所在而做出的选择。所以，你会去寻找它，而在你去寻找它的过程中，你将建立技能，
you're going to meet new people, you're going to see new places, you're going to under understand new industries, right? And you're just going to go try stuff. And I think it's a beautiful thing to do for people in their 20s. And I'll tell you, my favorite example, Matthew Beconaghey, who roughly everyone in the world loves. He's here in Austin, where I am. He did, this is a really neat segue for me and you. So Matthew Beconaghani is from Austin, and he did his experiment path in Australia.
你将结识新朋友，你将看到新地方，你将了解新行业，对吧？然后你就会去尝试各种东西。我认为对于二十多岁的人来说，这是一件非常美好的事情。我来告诉你我最喜欢的例子：马修·麦康纳（Matthew McConaughey），世界上几乎所有人都很喜欢他。他就住在奥斯汀，也就是我现在所在地。他曾走过——对我俩来说这是一个非常绝妙的过渡——所以马修·麦康纳来自奥斯汀，他在澳大利亚开启了他的实验道路。
So when he was very young, like 18 years old, he went and spent a year in Australia. It's in his biography called Greenlights. Yeah. And he did like six fundamentally different jobs in Australia, just completely different stuff. Like, you know, law clerk and engine mechanic and lifeguard and I'm just making these things up. I don't remember what it were. And probably like fruit picking. Yeah.
所以当他非常年轻的时候，比如18岁左右，他去澳大利亚待了一年。这写在他的自传《绿灯》（Greenlights）里。是的。他在澳大利亚做过大约六种截然不同的工作，完全是不同的那种。比如，你知道的，法律文员、发动机机械师、救生员——我只是瞎编的这些。我不记得具体是什么了。可能还有像摘水果之类的。是的。
He just did these completely different jobs. And the point was to just sort of. open your mind to all of the things that exist in this world. And that's, you know, something I, I'd like to, I'll plant this seat and maybe we'll have a separate conversation. I need to write an article about this. And this is something I feel really strongly about now because I have a 17-year-old daughter and she's applying to college nowish in the next, you know, one, two, three months. And what the universities are telling her is convince us that you know what you're passionate about and that you're going to major in it and that you're going to graduate
他就是做了这些完全不同的工作。而重点就是去，你知道的，向这个世界上存在的所有事物敞开你的心扉。这就是，你知道的，我想留下的一个伏笔，也许我们以后可以单独聊聊。我需要写一篇关于这个的文章。这也是我现在深有感触的一件事，因为我有一个17岁的女儿，她现在或即将在这头的一两个月内申请大学。而大学告诉她的是：说服我们，你知道自己对什么充满激情，并且你将以此为主修专业，你将会毕业，
and that you're going to get a job in that field. And I just think that's such a disservice. How the hell is a 17-year-old supposed to know that? Some of them do, but I think most of them don't. And so now there's this industry of consultants who are teaching 17-year-olds how to pretend to universities that they know what they're passionate about. It's awful. And so I think what, because You know, by definition, at that age, you haven't seen all that. You don't know what strategy consulting is, right? Yeah, I mean, there's so many things in the world. Like, I like to look around me and think, you know, somebody specializes in how to make monitors or ice machines.
并且你将在这个领域找到一份工作。而我只是觉得这完全是一种荼毒。一个17岁的孩子怎么可能会知道这些？！他们当中有些人确实知道，但我认为绝大多数人并不知道。所以现在涌现出了这样一个咨询行业，教17岁的孩子们如何向大学伪装他们知道自己对什么充满激情。这太糟糕了。所以我认为，因为，你知道的，按照定义，在这个年龄，你还没见过所有这些。你根本不知道什么是战略咨询，对吧？是的，我的意思是，世界上有太多事情了。就像我喜欢环顾四周，然后心想：你知道的，总有人专门研究如何制造显示器或制冰机。
I mean, like, all these things. And you don't know that yet. You've got to go into the world and see all these things that are being done to find that spark of something you might love. And so, like, insisting that at 17, you're supposed to know. that I think is a real disservice to young people. It's something I hear about all the time where it's like what you're meant to decide. Like your brain is still a decade away from maturation. You haven't had any kind of really truly independent experiences.
我的意思是，所有这些事情。而你现在还不知道。你必须走进这个世界，去看所有这些正在被做的事情，去寻找那个你可能热爱的火花。所以，非要坚持认为在17岁时你就应该知道这一切，我认为这对年轻人来说真的是一种荼毒。这是我一直听到的一种观点，就像是：这就是注定要由你来做决定的事情。你的大脑距离完全成熟其实还要再过十年。你根本没有经历过任何真正完全独立的经历。
You've probably only seen at 0.002% of the world. And they're like, cool, lock yourself into this path, strap yourself in. And if you're not happy, well, quitting that, that's a sign of failure. that's a sign that you don't have a willingness or you don't have grit or you don't have discipline. And my sister is also 17 and I was talking to her about it. And I was like, my best advice is to just choose whatever you care about the most right now. And then just take as many electives as possible, travel as much as possible. Like I went to university.
你大概只见过这个世界万分之二的面貌。然后他们却说：太棒了，把自己锁死在这条路上吧，系好安全带。如果你不开心，好吧，那选择放弃就是失败的标志，那是你缺乏意愿、缺乏毅力或缺乏纪律的标志。我妹妹也是17岁，我之前跟她聊过这件事。我的最佳建议就是：选择目前你最在乎的事情。然后尽可能多地选修各种课程，尽可能多地去旅行。就像我上大学时，
I did economics and politics. I really do not talk about that now. But it was just the experience of being around like-minded people who cared about things that also. really like push me to that point. This kind of segues into my next question, which is, why do you think people feel such a pressure, again, to choose something, to say this is who I am, and to maybe never walk away from it?
我学的是经济学和政治学。我现在其实根本不谈论那些。但仅仅是置身于那些志同道合、关心某些事情的人群中的经历，也确实把我推向了那个方向。这有点像我下一个问题的过渡：你认为为什么人们会感受到如此巨大的压力——再次强调——去选择某个东西，去宣称这就是我是谁，并且可能永远不要背离它？
Is that something that you've seen a lot of people do maybe in later decades of their life? Sure. So just to wrap on that last question of the experiment path, I think it's much better advice to do what Matthew McConaughey did. Go to Australia and do six jobs for a year. Or like people who's called a gap year. Like go expose yourself to the world because you might find something else that you can be passionate about. You might find your passion.
这难道是你在人们生命的后几个十年里看到很多人都在做的事吗？当然。所以，为了结束关于实验道路的最后一个问题，我认为最好的建议其实是去做马修·麦康纳做过的事。去澳大利亚，花一年时间做六份工作。或者就像人们所说的“间隔年”（gap year）。去让自己接触这个世界，因为你可能会发现其他你可以为之充满激情的事物。你可能会找到你的激情。
You might just fall in love. I mean, whatever. You got to get out there, right? Yeah. So I'm a big fan of exposing yourself to the world, doing a gap year, all that kind of thing, as opposed to pretending that you know what you're passionate about. So why do people feel pressured to declare their passion early on? So from a university point of view, there is this really understandable but ultimately sad rationale.
你可能会直接坠入爱河。我的意思是，不管怎样。你得走出去，对吧？是的。所以我是让自己接触世界、进行间隔年以及所有这类事情的超级大粉丝，而不是去假装你知道自己对什么充满激情。那么，为什么人们会感到压力，要很早就宣布自己的激情所在呢？所以，从大学的角度来看，存在着一种非常可以理解但最终却令人悲伤的逻辑。
So the universities in the United States, and it's probably not different in Australia, but I don't know. I know it's true here. They're very focused on rising up in the rankings. You know, like Forbes and U.S. New World Report, these magazines will rank universities. And those rankings are based on metrics. And the metrics include things like graduation rate or like percentage of people, I don't want to say kids, people who graduate in four or five years, percentage of people who have a job within three months after graduation, average starting salary. And it turns out for at least the best universities, if you pick up. those people who are 17 years old and they do know what they're passionate about they do
美国的大学——澳大利亚可能也没什么不同，但我不知道。我知道这里确实如此——它们非常专注于在排名中往上爬。你知道的，比如《福布斯》（Forbes）和《美国新闻与世界报道》（U.S. News & World Report），这些杂志会对大学进行排名。而这些排名是基于各种指标的。这些指标包括诸如毕业率，或者在毕业后四五年内毕业的人的比例，毕业后三个月内找到工作的比例，平均起薪等等。事实证明，至少对于顶尖大学来说，如果你挑选出那些17岁并且确实知道自己对什么充满激情的年轻人，他们在这些指标上的表现会更好，对吧？
better on those metrics right they're more likely to graduate because they're studying something they like they're more likely to get a job because they're passionate about it and they're more likely to get paid well down the line because they're doing something you're passionate about so from a good university point of view you're creating this incentive for people to lie to you because what you really want those people, right? You want those 17-year-olds who know exactly what they want. That's who you want because they're going to drive your numbers up. So it's this really sort of perverse incentive that that's become the predominant message to very young people. Like you got to do what you're passionate about. And you don't. Like I think telling someone that their work and their passion
他们更有可能毕业，因为他们在学习自己喜欢的东西；他们更有可能找到工作，因为他们对它充满激情；而且由于他们在从事自己热心的事情，他们长远来看更有可能获得丰厚的报酬。所以，从一所优秀大学的角度来看，你正在为人们创造一种激励机制，让他们向你撒谎，因为这正是你真正想要的那些人，对吧？你想要那些确切知道自己想要什么的17岁年轻人。这就是你想要的，因为他们会推高你的各项数据。所以这变成了一种非常反常的激励机制，成为了向极度年轻的人传递的主导信息：你必须去做你充满激情的事情。而你根本不必如此。就像我认为告诉一个人“你的工作和你的激情必须是同一回事”是一个错误，因为这并不是真的。对吧？就像对我来说，
has to be the same thing is a mistake because it's not true. Right. Like for me, you know, I'm running a bunch of businesses. I would. probably be failing if I tried to do that at 20 years old. I had to do 20 years of, and it wasn't paying dues. I loved what I was doing. But I learned so much and I got financial security so that, you know, I started to follow my passion. I had a much higher probability of success because I had on these capabilities and I had the ability to fund scaling up some of my companies. So I think telling 20 somethings, you should work at what you're doing. you're passionate about now, I think it's a mistake. I think that's true for 20% of them.
你知道的，我经营着一堆公司。如果我在20岁时尝试做这些，我可能会一败涂地。我必须经历20年的——并且这并不是在“还债”。我热爱我所做的事情。但我学到了太多，我也获得了财务安全，这样，你知道的，当我开始追求我的激情时，我成功的概率要高得多，因为我具备了这些能力，并且我有能力资助扩大我的一些公司的规模。所以我认为告诉二十多岁的人：你应该从事你现在就充满激情的工作——我认为这是一个错误。我认为这只对20%的人适用。
I'm looking at it now. Literally you have the data. I'm looking at it right here. Yeah. And additionally, I just think that it's like, I always say this to people. Firstly, I loved what you just told me about the universities. I had no idea that that was the case. But anytime someone says you should be doing this, know that the should benefits them. Like, if someone is so hell bent on getting you to do something a certain way, there's an ulterior motive, always. And secondly, like, I get all of these questions from people being like, I don't know what I want to do with my life. You have so much time to figure it out. Like, you genuinely do. I love surrounding myself with examples of people who just pivot and shift later in life and who just do really cool things.
我现在正看着呢。真的，你有数据。我就在这儿看着呢。对。此外，我觉得就像我总是对人们说的那样。首先，我太喜欢你刚才跟我讲的关于大学的事了。我完全不知道原来是这样。但每当有人说你应该这么做时，你要知道这个“应该”对他们是有利的。就像，如果有人非要让你按某种特定方式去做某事，那背后一定有不可告人的动机，永远都是。其次，比如说，我收到人们各种各样的问题，他们会说：“我不知道自己的人生想做什么。”你有大把的时间去弄清楚。真的有。我喜欢身边环绕着这样的人：他们在生活的后期突然转向和改变，并做着真正酷的事情。
And it's like all it, it's this hindsight, right? All of these little, all these little things like actually contribute to this final goal. So we are going to take a short break here. But when we return, I do want to talk about what occurs when people are pursuing their ideal career path and how you can determine it. And why, again, people feel so much pressure to have it all figured out. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the third.
这就像所有这一切，都是马后炮，对吧？所有这些小事情，所有这些小细节其实都促成了这个最终的目标。所以我们在这里要作一个短暂的休息。但当我们回来时，我确实想谈谈当人们追求自己理想的职业道路时会发生什么，以及你该如何确定它。为什么人们又会感到如此大的压力，非要把一切都弄清楚不可。所以请继续收听我们的节目。百分之二。这就是选择走第三条
stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong, many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever
楼梯（而不是坐扶梯）的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗挫力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油天生具有炎性。我们搞错了，我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题其实都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。这就是 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 T-W-O-Persent。
you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，千万别惹乡下姑娘。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。法则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是这么说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《闺蜜》的新季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个惯犯骗子约会过。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定亲自动手。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他一定会得到应有的惩罚。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。
On the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击莉尔·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不只是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，说到这儿，马克，这是我们第二集讨论可卡因了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在台面上谈。谢谢你帮我把话说完。我不认为还有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？对。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难学艺》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我将带来我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追寻某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世界上活着做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹是因为想成为一个好人。
Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《艰难学艺》中，就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeart Radio 应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这就引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你对这份特定的测试做了两次手脚，对吗？我做过一次手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大队才能破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is my next big line of questioning for you. So just as a little revision. for people who we did talk about it right at the top of the episode. The five career paths are independent, money, passion, experiment, and balanced.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。这是我对你的下一系列重大质询。所以作为一点小复习。对于我们刚才在节目最开始讨论过的人来说。这五种职业路径是：独立、金钱、热情、实验和平衡。
How do people identify which one of these is right for them right now? Is there like a feeling? Is there a state of mind, a state of flow that they can kind of look out for? Well, I think choosing one of the five paths is about this framework that I have in my book. It sounds complicated, but it's a four by three matrix. But just to explore those two axes for a second, the y-axis is, can I monetize a passion? And I've got four answers to that. Yes now.
人们如何确定这其中哪一条最适合他们呢？有没有那种感觉？有没有一种心境或心流状态是他们可以去留意的？嗯，我觉得选择这五条路径中的一条，取决于我在书里提出的这个框架。听起来很复杂，但它是一个四乘三的矩阵。为了探究这两个坐标轴，Y 轴是：我能否将热情变现？对此我有四个答案。现在可以。
Yes, later. I don't know, which typically means I don't know if a passion is. And no, I cannot monetize the passion. And I like to joke that if your only passion is smoking pot and playing video games, the answer might be no. And then I've got this professor, friend of mine who says you can monetize both smoking pot and playing video games. I was going to say, uh, I know it's crazy these things. Being in the pot business and being in a video game business, but smoke and pot and
以后可以。我不知道，这通常意味着我不知道某种热情是否可以。以及不，我无法将热情变现。我喜欢开玩笑说，如果你的唯一热情就是抽大麻和打电子游戏，那么答案可能就是“不能”。然后我有位教授朋友说，你既能把抽大麻变现，也能把打电子游戏变现。我本来想说，呃，我知道这很疯狂，这些事情。从事大麻生意和电子游戏生意，但是抽大麻和
playing video games, that's really hard to monetize it. Yeah. And then that's one. And then the X axis is need for financial security, high, medium low. And I've got in the tool and in the book, there's like these 10, uh, questions and you score them one to 10 and you add it up. And it, it tells you whether you're high or medium or low. And so then the five paths are plotted on that matrix. So you figure out which square you're in, and it will say, this is the right path for you. And for most of them, there's a choice of one or two. And then it really narrows it down.
打电子游戏，要将这些变现真的很难。是的，这是其一。然后 X 轴是对财务安全的需求：高、中、低。我在工具和书里设计了大约 10 个问题，你给它们打 1 到 10 分然后加起来。它就能告诉你你的需求是高、中还是低。然后这五条路径就被绘制在这个矩阵上。所以你算出自己落在哪个方格里，它就会说，这就是适合你的路径。对大多数方格来说，只有一到两个选择。这就大大缩小了范围。
A couple of easy examples. If the answer to the question, can I monetize a passion? If the answer is yes now and your need for financial security is low, well, then the answer is the passion path. Right, why would you not, right? If you have the capability and the desire to monetize a passion now and you're not worried about money, go for it. Conversely, if your need for financial security is high and like you're just, you're not going to be comfortable until you got a financial cushion, that is going to push you toward the money path. If you don't know what your passion is, that's going to push you to the experiment path. And so you just you go through the framework and it'll help you, you know, pick one of the five. See, I like this.
举几个简单的例子。如果对“我能否将热情变现？”这个问题的回答是“现在可以”，而你对财务安全的需求很低，那么答案就是“热情路径”。对吧，为什么不呢？如果你现在有能力也有意愿将热情变现，而且又不担心钱的问题，那就去干吧。相反，如果你对财务安全的需求很高，而且比如说，除非你有了财务缓冲，否则你根本不会安心，那就会把你推向“金钱路径”。如果你不知道你的热情是什么，那就会把你推向“实验路径”。所以你只需要走一遍这个框架，它就会帮你挑选出这五种路径之一。你看，我喜欢这个。
This is the kind of stuff that my mind really enjoys is frameworks, data, and the evidence. And I feel like that's what a lot of people are looking for is like, I don't need to know exactly what I'm going to do, but I do want to know what kind of general steps I should take. I do have a question about the people who are really focused on the money path. Have you, is there some maybe personality aspect or maybe cultural things? that you've noticed for the people who are quite focused on gaining financial security or finding a lot of financial success in their work? Yeah, I think it's not a personality type from a psychology point of view. It's not like a Big Five thing or an MBTI thing.
这正是我脑子非常喜欢的东西：框架、数据和证据。我觉得这也是很多人正在寻找的：我不需要确切知道我要做什么，但我确实想知道我应该采取什么样的大体步骤。我确实有一个问题，关于那些非常专注于金钱路径的人。你有没有发现，对于那些非常专注于获得财务成功或在工作中追求巨大财务成就的人来说，有没有什么潜在的个性特质或文化因素？是的，我觉得从心理学的角度来看，这不属于某种人格类型。这不像是个“大五人格”或“MBTI”测试。
I think it tends to be a, I think it's a family history thing. So I'll tell you the exemplar I use, who's a guy I respect a lot. He's a podcaster now. His name is Scott Galloway. Have you heard of Scott Galloway? You know what? I feel like I have. He's a big influencer and, you know, as a professor at the Stern School of Business at New York University, very, very popular.
我觉得这往往关乎家庭历史。所以我给你讲讲我用过的榜样，那是一个我很尊敬的人。他现在是个播客主。他叫斯科特·加洛韦。你听说过斯科特·加洛韦吗？你知道吗？我觉得我听说过。他是个大网红，你知道的，作为纽约大学斯特恩商学院的教授，非常非常受欢迎。
And he's my exemplar for the money path. And I'll tell you how he got there. How he got there's three things. One is he grew up very poor. And he had this experience, and he was in the northern part of the U.S. I don't remember it's Wisconsin or Michigan or whatever. One of those places where it gets cold. It doesn't really get cold here in Texas.
他是我心目中金钱路径的榜样。我来告诉你他是怎么走到这一步的。他走到这一步有三件事。第一，他从小非常穷。他有过这样一段经历，当时他在美国北部。我不记得是威斯康星州还是密歇根州什么的。那些天很冷的地方。德克萨斯州这里其实不太冷。
And he lost his coat. And he was afraid to tell his mother that he lost his coat because he knew that the $30 to replace it would be really painful. She didn't tell her. So then he came home from school one day and it's 20 degrees outside. And he's shivering and red. And his mother's like, where's your coat, man? And he had to say that he lost it. And that kind of scarred him a little bit.
他弄丢了自己的外套。他不敢告诉他母亲自己把外套弄丢了，因为他知道花 30 美元换一件新外套会给家里带来沉重的负担。他没告诉母亲。结果有一天他放学回家，外面只有零下六度（20华氏度）。冷得直哆嗦，脸冻得通红。他母亲就问：“孩子，你的外套呢？”他不得不承认自己把它弄丢了。那件事对他的内心造成了一点创伤。
And then fast forward, you know, 15 years. He was in his 20s. And he was doing well, but his mother got cancer. And there were some treatments that they could have tried if they had money. And they didn't. And that scarred him again. And so he decided he had to be a rich. And so he went into investment banking.
然后快进，你知道的，15 年后。他二十多岁。他当时发展得不错，但他的母亲得了癌症。如果他们有钱的话，本来有一些治疗方法是可以尝试的。但他们没有。那件事再次给他留下了创伤。于是他决定自己必须变得富有。所以他去了投资银行，
and he went to Morgan Stanley and he did to get rich thing. And I, you know, one could argue, see, he wasn't on the balanced path because in the balanced path, you may be building wealth, but it's with an eye towards switching to the passion path later.
他去了摩根士丹利，开始走发家致富之路。而且，你知道，有人可能会争辩说，看，他当时并不在平衡路径上，因为在平衡路径上，你可能也在积累财富，但那是为了以后转向热情路径。
What he did, though, is he got so wealthy that he got off of the money path, and now I think he's on the passion path. He's a podcaster and an influencer, and he's trying to do some good for the world. but he was on the money path because that was not the goal. He kind of figured that out later. And I thought it's really important for people on the money path
不过，他所做的是，他变得如此富有，以至于他脱离了金钱路径，现在我认为他走上了热情路径。他是一名播客主兼网红，他正试图为世界做一些好事。但他当时走的是金钱路径，因为那并不是最终目标。他后来才算明白了这一点。我觉得对于走金钱路径的人来说，这一点非常重要。
is, in my opinion, there's two different views on high wealth. One view is more is better. And the other view is enough is enough. And I'm very convinced, and I should do this survey somehow, that the more is better people are much less happy. than the enough is enough people. Because the more is better people, they never stop from the money path.
在我看来，对于巨大的财富有两种不同的看法。一种看法是“多多益善”。另一种看法是“知足常乐”。我非常确信——我应该以某种方式做个调查——“多多益善”的人要比“知足常乐”的人幸福得多。因为“多多益善”的人，他们在金钱路径上永远不会停下来。
They keep going. They're like hamsters on a wheel. They just can't get off. The enough is enough people, they can get off of the money path. Yeah. And they can switch to the passion path when they think, okay,
他们一直在往前冲。他们就像轮子上的仓鼠。根本停不下来。“知足常乐”的人，他们可以从金钱路径上下来。是的。当他们觉得差不多了，就可以转向热情路径。
I mean, like Scott Galloway's net worth is over $100 million. You can't spend that much money. You have to wake up and try to spend that much money. Yeah. And so he's in enough as enough person. So now he's, you know, doing stuff that he's,
我是说，就像斯科特·加洛韦的净资产超过了 1 亿美元。你根本花不完那么多钱。你得特意醒来想方设法去花那么多钱。是的。所以他是一个知足常乐的人。因此现在他正在做他认为
thinks it's good for the world. You know how you mentioned that you want to do a study on this? Do you know the term the hedonic treadmill or hedonic? Yeah. Yeah. That's like the rat in the wheel is buy something new and six months later or six weeks later it doesn't bring you happiness anymore. It's just normal. And they've done all these studies. Well, they haven't done a lot, but there's a particularly famous one about people who win the lottery. And people who get paralyzed that I've talked about on the podcast before. And you would expect, like, if I make all this money, my life is going to change. But then, of course, it actually goes back to a relatively stable level. And I would assume that people who are like, the more, more, more people,
对世界有益的事情。你知道你刚才提到你想对此做个研究吗？你知道“享乐适应”或“享乐跑步机”这个词吗？知道。对。那就像笼子里的老鼠，买了一件新东西，六个月后或六周后它不再给你带来快乐了。它就变得稀松平常了。他们做过所有这些研究。好吧，他们没有做过很多，但有一个特别著名的研究是关于中彩票的人的，以及关于瘫痪的人的，我在之前的播客里聊过。你会预料到，如果我赚了这么多钱，我的生活就会改变。但当然，它最终实际上会回到一个相对稳定的水平。我猜想那些“多多益善”的人，
their only hit is coming from gaining wealth. And so they're on this, like, hedonic treadmill of like, okay, when I get here, I'll be happy. And they think that they're an enough is enough person but they're not they are actually a more is more person be so interesting to see like the distinction between like the psychological drivers behind these people and like yeah because i yeah it would be fascinating to uh you know disaggregate people and wealthy people into more as better and enough is enough and then tests that against their happiness and their fulfillment and their productivity and their relationships with friends and family and their physical health because i would bet um i would bet that the enough is enough people score better on a lot of life outcomes,
他们唯一的快乐来源就是获取财富。所以他们陷入了这种享乐跑步机中，心想：“好吧，等我达到这个目标，我就会快乐了。”他们觉得自己是个知足常乐的人，但其实并不是，他们实际上是个贪得无厌的人。看看这些人的心理驱动力之间的区别会非常有趣，因为，是的，把普通人和富人区分为“多多益善”和“知足常乐”，然后对照他们的幸福感、成就感、生产力、与亲友的关系以及身体健康状况进行测试，这会非常迷人。因为我敢打赌，
the more is better people. Oh, yeah. Totally, because it's also like they can relax at some stage and they can give back. And we know that generosity and pro-social spending is like super empowering. Which kind of brings me to this next question that I have, which is specifically for people in their 20s. How do you recommend we handle comparison within our career part?
我敢打赌在许多生活成果上，“知足常乐”的人得分会比“多多益善”的人更高。哦，对。完全如此，因为这也是因为他们在某个阶段能够放松下来，并且能够回馈社会。我们知道慷慨和亲社会支出是非常具有赋能作用的。这自然引出了我的下一个问题，这个问题是专门针对二十多岁的年轻人的。你推荐我们如何在职业道路上处理攀比问题？
So seeing people make more money than us, seeing people know what their passion is, seeing people being able to monetize their passion, how do we manage that? You have to just not do it, right? You have to not do it. Your social comparison is useless. And so I'll give you two kind of thoughts. One is a good friend of mine as a professor of business strategy at Texas A&M. And his saying that he says all the time is, Today is a good day to be better than I was yesterday. He just says it all the time. And then I've got a buddy. He's one of the best full contact jousters in the world. It's his thing, right? It's his passion.
看到别人赚比我们多的钱，看到别人知道自己的热情所在，看到别人能够将自己的热情变现，我们该如何应对？你必须不去跟别人比，对吧？你必须克制不去这样做。你的社会比较毫无用处。所以我给你两个想法。第一个想法，我的一个好朋友是德克萨斯农工大学的企业战略教授。他经常挂在嘴边的一句话是：“今天是个好日子，因为我要比昨天的自己更好。”他总是这么说。然后我还有一个哥们儿。他是世界上最优秀的场地全接触马上长矛比武选手之一。这就是他的事业，对吧？这就是他的热情所在。
And he says, you know, I'm not competing with anyone. I'm competing to be better than I was yesterday. And so then here's what might be a tip. It comes from atomic habits by James Clear. And it's this mathematical reality that one, 0.0 raised to the 365th power is 1.0.1. So 1% more raised to the 365th power is 37. 37 versus 1. So if you can get 1% better every day, you're going to be 37 times better at the end of the year. And maybe 1% every day is too much, but get 1% better every month or every quarter.
他说：“你知道的，我不跟任何人竞争。我只在竞争着让自己比昨天更好。”那么，这里可能有一个小贴士。它来自詹姆斯·克利尔的《原子习惯》。这是一个数学现实：1 加上 0.0（译者注：原文如此，即 1.01）的 365 次方是 37.8。所以 1% 的微小进步乘以 365 次方是 37。37 对比 1。所以如果你每天能进步 1%，到年底你就会好 37 倍。也许每天进步 1% 太夸张了，但你可以每个月或每个季度进步 1%。
or every year. And that's all you really need to do. You know, screw what everybody else is doing. Get 1% better. And I'm sure you've seen that work. I've seen that work. Like I'm running a half marathon on the weekend. I couldn't run 3Ks when I first, at the start of the year. And it's just also committing to being slow and steady and understanding, and if you're a frequent listener of the podcast, you will know this analogy.
或者每年进步 1%。而这正是你真正需要做的。你知道的，别管别人在干什么。让自己进步 1%。我确信你见过这种方法的成效。我见过它起作用。比如我这个周末要跑半程马拉松。今年刚开始的时候，我连 3 公里都跑不下来。这也关乎承诺要循序渐进、脚踏实地，并且你要明白——如果你是本播客的忠实听众，你就会知道这个比喻：
comparison is not a ladder, it is a circle. We often assume that it's like, oh, there's someone who's better than me, and there's someone who's better than them, and there's someone at the very top who has everything. Actually, you're comparing yourself to Jill, who's comparing yourself to Joe, who's comparing himself to Michael, who's comparing himself to you. Every single person has something that someone else does not have,
攀比不是一座梯子，而是一个圆圈。我们经常假设，哦，这里有一个比我优秀的人，还有一个比那个人更优秀的人，而在最顶端有一个拥有一切的人。实际上，你是在拿自己和吉尔作比较，吉尔在拿自己和乔作比较，乔在拿自己和迈克尔作比较，而迈克尔又在拿自己和和你作比较。每个人都有别人没有的东西，
and that person has something that you don't have. And so understanding that, like, you are comparing based on a figment of, of your insecurity, you imagine their life as being amazing because you aren't sure that your life is. That was like the real key that unlocked it for me where I was like, okay, this is me just trying to sabotage me using this person as like an excuse. I love it. I love what you're saying because this is all, this is all inside of you, right? So you're better at running a half marathon this month than you were last month. And I can see. the smile on your face, you're taking pride in getting better at your goal of a half marathon.
而那个人也有你没有的东西。所以要明白这一点：你的攀比是基于你自身不安全感的虚构产物，你把别人的生活想象得无比美好，因为你不确定自己的生活是否美好。这就是那个真正解开我心结的关键点，当时我想：好吧，这其实是我自己在借用这个人作为借口来搞砸我自己。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢你所说的了，因为这一切，这一切都在你内心，对吧？所以你这个月跑半程马拉松的表现就是比上个月好。我能看到
What could you be doing? You could be going, look at this person who can run a marathon every week. They're so cool and I'm so bad, right? I'm so envious because they're awesome. That would be completely useless to you. And think about how much happy you are as a human because your mindset is I'm better than it was last month and that's great. You know what? I'm going to get better next month too, and I'm going to achieve this goal. Like, that's a really positive and productive mindset. Speaking of advice, we have one, well, I have one final question for you. We ask every single listener this question, which is, what is one thing you wish you had known in your 20s, one piece of advice that has nothing to do with what we talked about today?
你脸上的笑容，你正为自己跑半程马拉松的目标取得了进步而感到自豪。你本来可以怎么做呢？你本可以去想：“看看这个人，他每周都能跑马拉松。他们太酷了，而我太差劲了，对吧？我太嫉妒了，因为他们太棒了。”那样对你来说完全毫无用处。想想看，作为一个人，你的心态是“我比上个月表现得更好，这太棒了”，这让你有多么快乐。你知道吗？我下个月也会变得更好，我会实现这个目标的。你看，这真是一个非常积极和富有成效的心态。说到建议，我们还有一个，嗯，我有一个最后的问题要问你。我们向每一位听客都提出过这个问题，那就是：有什么是你希望自己在二十多岁时就知道的？有没有一条建议是和我们今天讨论的内容完全无关的？
Take care of your body. And I'm going to give you the mathematical reason to take care of your body. So there's this idea of maximum heart rate, which is 220 minus your age. So if you're, the math is easy for 20 years old, your maximum heart rate is 200. So then there's all these correlations that are about to happen. If you can get your heart rate to 60% of maximum, at least 30 minutes a day, at least five days a week, that's the independent variable. And you can do that on anything, but 60% of maximum heart rate, which would be 120 beats per minute if you're 20 years old, at least 30 minutes a day, at least five days a week. Here come the correlations. negatively correlated with heart disease, which is the number one killer,
照顾好你的身体。我要给你一个照顾好身体的数学原因。这里有一个最大心率的概念，即 220 减去你的年龄。所以如果你是——对于 20 岁的人来说，计算很简单，你的最大心率是 200。接下来将有一系列相关性出现。如果你能让你的心率达到最大心率的 60%，每天至少 30 分钟，每周至少 5 天，这就是自变量。你可以通过任何运动来实现这一点，但达到最大心率的 60%——如果你 20 岁的话，大约是每分钟 120 次心跳——每天至少 30 分钟，每周至少 5 天。相关性来了：
negatively correlated with cancer, which is the number two killer, negatively correlated with anxiety, depression, and suicide attempts. Positively correlated correlated with longevity, happiness, IQ, sex appeal, is negatively correlated with all the worst things and positively correlated with all the best things. I mean, think about happiness, longevity, and IQ, you, what the hell else do you want? Yeah.
它与心脏病呈负相关，而心脏病是头号杀手；
And so when I make this impassioned plea to students, I'm like, there is not a better case for a human being to do anything in this life than that case I just made you. It is not possible to make a better case than that. So please find that thing that you can do with your body. And at my age, a brisk walk will do it, right? Yeah. Find that thing. It might be tennis or swimming or weightlifting or it could do anything, right?
与癌症呈负相关，癌症是第二大杀手；与焦虑、抑郁和自杀未遂呈负相关。它与长寿、幸福感、智商、性吸引力呈正相关，与所有最糟糕的事情呈负相关，与所有最好的事情呈正相关。我是说，想想幸福感、长寿和智商，你，还要什么自行车？是的。
Whatever it is, find that thing. Well, I love that advice. I think that's like, no one's ever given it before either. So that's always a good thing. I love it. And I just want to thank you again for coming on. This conversation has honestly been so fun for me, which is always like a good way to end interviews. And I just love what you're putting out into the world.
因此，当我向学生们发出这番充满激情的呼吁时，我说：在这个世界上，没有任何一个理由比我刚刚对你说的那个理由更能成为人类去做某件事的佐证了。不可能再找出比这更好的理由了。所以请找到那件你能用你的身体去做的运动。到了我这个年龄，快走就足够了，对吧？是的。找到那项运动。可能是网球、游泳、举重，或者任何别的什么，对吧？
So yeah, I want to say a big thank you. Where can people find you as well? They can finally at georgeampling.com. Cool. And I'm going to leave a link in the description for George's book. I know a lot of psychology students do listen to the podcast. If you are interested in organizational psychology specifically, I think this is a good companion, especially if you want to practice and you want to practice with people who are in emerging
无论它是什么，找到它。嗯，我很喜欢这个建议。我觉得这也是从没有人给过的建议。所以这总是一件好事。我太喜欢了。我只想再次感谢你作客节目。这次谈话对我来说真的非常有趣，这通常是结束采访的好方式。我太喜欢你向这个世界传递的内容了。
adulthood. Great. Great example of a book for that. So again, George, thank you so much. And thank you to everyone who has listened this far. If you have made it this far, leave in the course. comment below what you think your current career path is. Is it independent money, passion, experiment, or balanced? Let's see if we can like match George's numbers here and match his,
所以，是的，我要对你表示由衷的感谢。人们在哪里可以找到你呢？他们可以在 georgeampling.com 上找到我。太棒了。我会在简介里留下乔治的书的链接。我知道有很多心理学专业的学生在听这个播客。如果你对组织心理学特别感兴趣，我觉得这是一本很好的伴读指南，特别是如果你想进行实践，并且想和处于成年早期的人一起实践的话。
um, his statistics. As always, if you enjoy the podcast, leave a five star review, make sure you are following along and following us on Instagram at that psychology podcast. It's December guest month on the podcast. So we have some cool other guests coming in. Make sure that you are following us to see who they are. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle to your and we all talk very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist
这真的是一本很好的参考书。再次感谢你，乔治。也谢谢所有听到这里的听众。如果你坚持听到了最后，请在下方的评论区留下你认为你目前的职业路径是什么。是独立、金钱、热情、实验，还是平衡？让我们看看我们能否匹配乔治的数据，并匹配他的
and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
统计数据。一如既往，如果你喜欢这个播客，请留下五星好评，确保你关注了我们，并在 Instagram 上关注 @thatpsychology podcast。这是播客的“十二月嘉宾月”，所以我们还有其他一些很棒的嘉宾要来。确保关注我们以了解他们是谁。直到下次，注意安全。保持善良。对你的生活温柔以待，我们很快就会再聊！嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难学艺》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人穿着一套隐形的铠甲？它向世界发出信号：你可别想招惹我。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app. Apple Podcast or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学艺》。百分之二。这就是当有扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the,
在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗挫力的科学。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。这就是 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWO percent。
the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you.
当一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定亲自动手。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他绝不能就这么逃脱。他一定会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。
you got your podcast on the Look Back at it podcast For 1979 that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English Each episode we pick a year unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends, fellow comedians and favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s
你可以在《回顾过去》播客中听到...对1979年来说，那对我是个大时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。
84 was a wild year I don't think there's a more important year for black people Listen to Look Back at it on the I Heart Radio ad Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
84年是个疯狂的年份。我不认为还有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你对这份特定的测试做了两次手脚，对吗？我做过一次手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大队才能揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉利斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档 iHeart 播客。质量保证，真人录制。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。